I did not know what sober people did all
day when they weren't drinking is that's
what my entire life was if I wasn't
drunk I was thinking about when I could
get drunk next and if I couldn't afford
it I was thinking about what I could do
so I can go afford it I'm Kyle and I'm
an alcoholic but I haven't had a drink
in over two and a half years it's an
absolute miracle for me because I used
to drink every single day and I would
hardly draw sober breath alcohol wasn't
always the problem for me it actually
started off as the solution I was a kid
I was bullied a lot through I'm like
elementary school in middle school and I
couldn't really find a way to be okay
with myself so my first attempts at
trying to feel right with myself was
like video games and self-harm but they
never really brought me the relief that
I needed
I remember in eighth grade I finally had
a small group of friends and they were
all gonna go off after graduation and
drink beers and the forest I was raised
with like overbearing parents so I was
pretty nervous that I was gonna get
caught in getting the trouble but I
wanted to fit in more than anything else
I was excited and nervous and I had my
first beer and that was the only time in
my life that I only had one beer but the
second time I drank it was slightly
after my parents got divorced and we got
drunk and all that self-loathing went
away I finally felt like I fit in with
other people from then on it was just
like you know something I do with
friends and alcohol had become my
solution to my problems a little bit
afterwards alcohol is little magic
stopped wearing off as much and the
depression like started coming back
again eventually the alcohol made the
depression worse I had mentioned that I
had been self harming before and I
started doing that again and one day I
tried to take my own life and I was
putting on ambulance I was off to on the
hospital they were asking all these
questions about my drinking and I lied
because it was the one didn't add
for me they put me into a psychiatric
unit and my friend is like Kyle you
might have a problem with alcohol if you
want to go to AAA let me know and I said
no no no you don't understand in there I
learned all this stuff about mental
illnesses and this is this is what my
problem is and I drink again that night
I was in college at this time and I was
like failing half of my classes every
single semester and I decided like hey I
just really need to take a semester off
to kind of work on me and I didn't work
on me I did drank more and more and and
my dad found a new wife to marry and he
says all right Kyle we're gonna move
into our new house and you could come
with us but you can't drink there he
drink up there you're gonna have to
leave I got kicked out of their house
and I got sent back to live with my mom
again and this time we're both drinking
it was just a toxic household and this
is like probably a closed point of my
life I was just making everything worse
with alcohol and I was desperately
looking for anything that would fix me
so I'm about 24 years old and I get
kicked out at my mom's house for the
first time and she says okay you got to
sleep on the street for one day and then
you could come back so I slept on the
street for one day and she's like how
was it and I was just grumpy and I went
back next time she caught me drunk she
said okay now you're on the streets for
two days and the next time it's gonna be
three and my life was completely
unmanageable at this point I heard
somebody told me about a place called
midnight mission and Skid Row and he
said is a completely free treatment
program and I had exhausted every all my
resources so I decided I was gonna give
this alcohol to anonymous thing a try
they would take you on these vans from
Skid Row to the west side of LA which is
like super rich once again I was in a
room of Alcoholics Anonymous feeling
like a complete outsider and feel like I
couldn't relate to anybody in the room I
had holes in my teeth because of all
like cavities I was completely sunburned
I was like overweight and I'm looking at
all these people who have their lives
well put together and I'm looking for
somebody who's gonna help me or maybe
like have these classes at the midnight
mission like how to get a sponsor bother
somebody that's gonna has been in
Alcoholics Anonymous for a while who
understands what the steps are and he's
going to help me for completely free to
turn your life around
I couldn't actually ever remember
feeling pure joy because from the time
when I was a kid
to all it when I was in a duel I felt
like I was like maladjusted to life and
I couldn't deal with what the world was
giving me it was super helpful to have
so many in there that kind of like
understood it what it meant and who had
been through it himself and as I slowly
like tried to like you know put the
pieces back together in my life for some
reason I just held on and I held on
through it a little bit into my sobriety
my mother had passed away she actually
drank herself to death not everybody
makes it out I'm grateful that the AAA
is there for people who need it but not
everybody who needs it gets it and it's
one of the hardest parts because it took
me a while to like fully understand that
AAA was working for me so eventually I
finally found like my people they're my
family now one suggestion that was told
to me is if when you're feeling bad turn
your thoughts to somebody else that you
could help and it has always worked for
me because that entire time I was
drinking trying to fix myself when I was
trying anything to fix myself I can
never do it when I started focusing on
how I could best serve somebody else
that's when my life started turning
around that's when I was happy I don't
speak for a a as a whole but just like
for my personal experience with it and
all my aversions to it like when I
actually just find that you gave it like
a little bit of a chance that's what
we're not work for me
I highly recommend anybody can do things
that they may be an alcoholic just you
go and like maybe just check out AAA
even if you don't want to stay there
you'll always know where is if you ever
want to go back to the future the
Western Area Conference of young people
and Alcoholics Anonymous is a conference
that I'm on I was completely surprised
about how many other people like around
my age were actually sober when they had
previously had terrible problems with
drinking I always thought I was just
gonna be the odd one out with old people
in a room but really like I found like
my best friends in there I find the
people who I spend all my time with
night
I'm super grateful today cuz uh today I
do have a job and I've had the same job
for almost two years now I have a place
that live and I've never had my own
place to live in my entire life is the
first time in my life I've had that I
have best friends and I could tell
anything to and I guess spend all my
time with and I have just like so much
love my life I have and I finally have
peace I feel I finally have serenity
if I could go back in time I really wish
I could have gotten this sooner because
there seemed there could've been so much
suffering that couldn't have happened
and I wish I just have a more insight
that alcohol isn't this a big scary
thing it's just like okay there's an
indication of action that needs to be
done to be fixed
[Music]
[Music]